-Let's get to the news.
Well, it's 2024.
And you know what happens
later this year.
Oh, damn it!
I was gonna say the Olympics.
At a campaign rally
in Iowa last week,
former President Trump said that
President Biden,
"Can't put two sentences
together."
Um, have you heard him talk?
He can put, like, 100 together.
The same rally
in Iowa last week,
former President Trump
said that the Civil War,
"could have been negotiated."
That was crazy enough,
but then he said
the Gettysburg Address
could have been an e-mail.
Same rally, Trump also called
on President Biden
to release Capitol rioters
from prison.
And I guess it was
only a matter of time
before he settled on the same
campaign platform as the Joker.
Former UN Ambassador Nikki Haley
is facing criticism
after she recently
failed to cite slavery
as the leading cause
of the Civil War.
And not only that, she's facing
a D in social studies.
According to a new report,
when the violence began to
escalate in the Capitol attack,
then President Trump was
"just not interested
in doing more to stop it."
Either that,
or he was exhausted
from everything
he had to do to start it.
When asked yesterday
about reports that she could be
former President Trump's
running mate
in 2024,
Republican Congresswoman
Elise Stefanik said
she would be,
"honored to serve
in any capacity
in a Trump administration."
Well, I'm pretty sure First Lady
is gonna be up for grabs.
Apple announced today
that his Vision Pro headset
will launch next month.
This news first reported
on your hand,
your wrist, your lap
and pretty soon, your face.
After their dog recently ate
an envelope filled with $4,000,
a couple in Pennsylvania
was able to recover $3,500
in cash.
Said their friends,
"You can just Venmo me."
Taco Bell has begun offering
Crunchwrap Supreme meal kits
at Walmart,
which include tortillas,
crunchy tostada shells,
taco seasoning,
and Velveeta cheese sauce.
You can cook it at home,
then take it right out
to your car to eat it.
The largest radio company
in the country
announced over the weekend that
it has filed for bankruptcy.
If you haven't heard about it,
it's because they announced
it on the radio.
A man in Alabama
was arrested recently
after he allegedly crashed
his car outside
of a Bass Pro shop,
took off his clothes
and jumped into
the store's aquarium.
But I'm not gonna
make a joke about that
because it's low-hanging fruit.
Actually
after he jumped in the water,
it became high-hanging fruit.
Anybody who doesn't get it,
stay after
and we'll, like, do a...
Baz, I think told me
he drew a diagram.
We should offer more,
like, stay after
if you didn't get
any of the jokes.
Someone over there has got
a very stern face.
Keep them after.
And we'll be the only
talk show with detention.
And finally, the CDC has issued
a recall
for more than 11,000 pounds
of ready-to-eat meat products,
11,000 pounds of meat
or, as it's also known,
an Arby's Kid Meal.
Well, there we go.
Now you know it's a new year.
We've turned over
a new leaf on Arby's.
Hearing his speech
in South Carolina yesterday,
President Biden criticized
former President Trump
for attempting
to overturn the election
and called him a "loser."
Oh, come on, what has Trump
ever lost besides an airline,
his hotel, his golf course,
the popular vote twice,
the electoral vote once,
two wives, a casino,
most of his hair and his mind?
According to a newly
released document,
a Jeffrey Epstein accuser
claimed to have copies
of sex tapes
Epstein has made of former
President Trump.
And like most porn, it starts
with him ordering a pizza.
That's right.
A Jeffrey Epstein accuser
claimed to have a sex tape
of former President Trump --
I don't know.
I think if there was a sex tape,
we would have seen it by now...
in a Trump campaign ad.
[ As Trump ] I'm Donald Trump
and I approve of this porno.
[ Normal voice ]
A man in Portland
recently found a working iPhone
along the side of a road
that is believed to have been on
board the Alaskan Airlines plane
that had a door plug
blow off mid-flight.
And honestly, I'm not sure
what's scarier --
having the door
blow off your plane
or losing your phone.
84-year-old Maryland
Congressman Steny Hoyer
announced yesterday
that he will run for reelection.
Steny, man, you know you're old
when your name
doesn't even exist anymore.
It's like having
a congressman named Ramses.
In a speech yesterday,
Pope Francis
called for a universal ban
on surrogacy.
Okay. But it seemed to work out
for you in the past.
A truck driver from Illinois was
recently reunited with his cat,
nearly 700 miles away from where
she initially wandered off.
Or just as likely,
two cats were gray.
And finally, CNN Travel
recently published
an article titled
"The Most Exciting New Trains
Coming in 2024,"
which is hopefully
the "F" train.
In a new interview, Texas
Senator Ted Cruz said
that President Biden has done
"what no president
of either party has ever done
and ignored the rule of law."
Huh?
Wonder if Trump heard that...
from court.
One more sketch of this guy
and we can make
an animated series.
In his remarks
after his presidential
immunity hearing yesterday,
former President Trump claimed
that if he was in office,
there would be no war
in Ukraine or Israel. Really?
You couldn't even keep America
from attacking itself.
Trump also said
that there would be,
"bedlam in the country
if he's prosecuted."
Oh, I'm sure he's right.
Parade floats blocking traffic,
a massive champagne shortage.
You wouldn't be able
to walk a block
without a stranger
kissing you.
Also, he said
there would be bedlam?
I'm not sure
you can use that word
and then claim
the other guy is too old.
Not a lot of teens
using "bedlam."
New Jersey Senator
Robert Menendez
spoke on
the Senate floor yesterday
and defended himself
against accusations of bribery.
He said he refuses
to step down
unless someone is willing
to make it worth his while.
Boeing C.E.O. David Calhoun
reportedly held a staff-wide
meeting yesterday
after the FAA grounded dozens
of its 737 Max 9 planes.
He said if you need to talk,
his door is always blown open.
The food brand
Oscar Mayer is hiring
12 full-time drivers
for its Wienermobile,
which is still less embarrassing
than driving this Wienermobile.
Forbes magazine announced
this week
the unhealthiest states
in the country
and West Virginia ranks first.
I'm not surprised.
It even looks like something
Virginia needs to have removed.
This is very...
See, I knew.
I was gonna be bad at TV
for a second
because, like, I'm gonna
show you how I point,
but watch what happens
with my pencil.
Yeah. See?
And then I remembered before I
[bleep] up, I remembered.
Meta announced yesterday
it will begin removing
age-inappropriate content
from teenagers' Facebook feeds.
So if you see
a teenager on Facebook,
you're being catfished.
"Just saw your last picture.
Totally bedlam."
In a new interview,
actor Kevin Hart
said that he's in a group chat
with action-movie stars,
including Harrison Ford,
Tom Cruise and Jackie Chan.
But I'll bet I can guess all
their group-chat personalities.
Kevin Hart makes all the jokes.
Tom Cruise is the guy who uses
way too many exclamation points.
Jackie Chan puts a "Ha ha"
on everything,
and Harrison Ford
is not on that chat.
[ Grumbling ]
And finally, the brewer of
Miller Lite announced yesterday
that it's launching
new beer-flavored mints.
And if that goes well,
they might even start
offering beer-flavored beer.
Former new Jersey Governor
Chris Christie
announced yesterday
that he is ending
his presidential campaign
less than a week
before the Iowa caucuses.
That means last place
is now up for grabs.
The judge overseeing
his civil fraud trial today
allowed former President Trump
to speak for five minutes
after his legal team finished
their closing arguments,
and now he's facing
11 more counts of fraud.
Before he allowed
former President Trump
to address the court today,
Judge Arthur Engoron asked,
"Do you promise to just comment
on the facts and the law?"
Good luck.
That's like asking Jake,
"Do you promise you won't
talk about State Farm?"
During a Fox News
town hall last night,
former President Trump
took credit for overturning
Roe versus Wade.
Because, look, if he's got
to keep his kids, so do you.
At last night's town hall,
former President Trump
repeated his claim
that Florida governor
Ron DeSantis
would be working in a pizzeria
or a law firm
without his support.
And the fact that he thinks
those two jobs
are similar explains a lot
about his legal team.
[ As Trump ] "I found this guy.
He was at a pizza place.
Now he's my lawyer."
[ Normal voice ]
Trump also said he knows
who he wants to be
his running mate,
but added,
"I can't tell you that."
Well, of course not.
You'd be putting
their life in danger.
House Speaker Mike Johnson said
during an interview yesterday
that he's planning on calling
former President Trump
to walk him through his spending
deal with Senate Democrats.
God, what are you
gonna do next?
Walk a pigeon through Algebra?
Guess which one's
gonna take less time?
And "F" train derailed
yesterday in Brooklyn,
causing several hours
of normal "F" train service.
It was the same,
but with a reason.
The technology company
Augmental unveiled
a new device
this week called MouthPad,
which allows users to scroll
through their smartphones
by using their tongue.
Finally, a way to get
all the germs on my phone
directly into my body.
And finally,
the Coast Guard announced
that it recently seized
nearly 2,500 pounds of cocaine
in the Caribbean Sea.
The Coast Guard got suspicious
when they realized
all the fish were flying fish.
And that was a monologue,
everybody.